The stomach pain of not
eating absolutely anything is horrible and that's when you
realize that that idea begins to arise in
everyone at the same time and begins
to arise in everything without anyone speaking
to them the first comment I'm
sorry to Nando  parrado when I tell him there is
nothing left in the pantry and he tells me
Carlitos I eat the
pilot [Music]
Well I was born in
Montevideo my father's name was Carlos I
was always Carlito The son of the
famous painter because he was very famous I say dad
is without a doubt  one of the most famous guys
who passed through Uruguay somehow
I was a spoiled spoiled boy
spoil this very spoiled
breakfast in bed I had a babysitter at
that time and well that's how my
life went until I was 18 which is where
life changes  It changes as a result of a
eh that the Lord above God
changes the guide of
life for us I went to an Irish school Christian
brs college
and and the possibility of this trip arose
that was not only the rugby match
but it was eh you had to gather friends
so that the ticket was cheap and
we got this. So it was an
opportunity for all
teenagers to travel to a different country. The idea
was not only rugby, but it was to
buy different clothes, go out with girls
or pretend to go out with girls, that was
kind of the idea. So it was  everything was
joy, imagine and we felt alone
this The Owners of the world That is the
truth Then it was It was a moment of
complete happiness of a trip among
friends and a trip perhaps of weaning from
adolescence from depending on your
parents we were 40 people and  five
crew members,
we were 35 men, five women who
were relatives of some of the
passengers, this is a total of
45. Well, I felt happy, I loved
airplanes, the route we took now
was from Montevideo to Santiago.  from Chile
that you have to cross the
Andes Mountains we had to spend the night in
Mendoza which is the city before the
Mountains because the bad weather did not
allow us to cross the Mountains that day and
we resumed the trip the next day and well and
that plane left this direction  To Chile, well,
the plane began to cross the
Andes Mountains. I was sitting on the side of
the window of the plane and my
seatmate Rafael Echarren
asked me, Carlitos told me, let me have the
window, I want to take photos to
take to my girlfriend,
which
I  I take advantage as a spoiled person who was
like this spoiled person and everything it
cost me to give him the window because you saw
that spoiled people always want to be on the
side of the car or
plane window. But in the end, as I was the
youngest of all and he had me  What to do, the
mature man, I answered him with a certain arrogance, I
said yes, Rafael, sit down, I don't
care at all and he sat down happily to take
photos and I sat on the side of the hallway with
rage but trying not to let anyone
notice the rage I had.  I had
but that fact of destiny means that I
am here alive and he is not because minutes
after that episode one of the soldiers came out and
said, gentlemen, put on your seat
belts because the plane is going to dance for
a while and in fact we put on our seat
belts and the plane  It begins to
shake And suddenly we felt a gigantic pool of
air that we suddenly descended 600 m.
I remember that with
that unconsciousness of youth
we shouted ole like in the bullring and
then a second pool of air fell that we
returned to  shout ole but the sensation
was fear and the fear turns into
panic and suddenly we feel a
brutal acceleration of the plane's engine that
lifts its nose and we feel the most
brutal blow you can imagine when the
plane collides with the belly and with the  wing and
it splits in the middle and flies the
front part as if it were and falls on a
kind of ski slope as if it were
a sleigh and moves about 2 km with such
luck that we did not touch a single rock
because a single rock that we would have
touched  The fuselage would have
shattered but I remember that from the
inside I can tell you that when
I felt the
blow I started to pray and as a Catholic I
said I am going to pray the Our Father
which is what Christ taught us but
when I started to pray the Father  our
saying is not too long the
Our Father I am not going to finish it so
I am not going to look good with God and I start
praying an aem María the moment I
see her in shock and I finish praying
the aem María the moment I  The
fuselage finally stops but
of course throughout that Hail Mary many
things happened the plane that split in
half the most brutal cold that entered the
most absolute chaos the people that
spread out until it finally
stops abruptly all the seats
go to  in front We were all
squeezed between a huh
between the irons it was difficult for us
to realize that what was happening
to us was
happening to us well
we were left after the accident
among the people who died in the accident
and on that night there were 27 people left
You're 45 and I've never really
seen a dead person in my life. And suddenly you
find yourself surrounded by dead
people, surrounded by people screaming at 25 grams below zero without
resources of any kind in a world
that we didn't know
and many of us, it was a night that  Roy
Harley, one of the survivors, compares
what hell is like because it was a
night of horror, cold, dead, scared, hungry,
dead, I was without my mom, my
dad, and without my Nani. But the night
of horror happened.  and Saturday arrived and
Saturday was a splendid day in the
Cordillera, it seemed like a Swiss postcard. The
place where we fell, we
were surrounded by mountains, it was
like an amphitheater of
mountains, you could only see a valley
ahead, the place was
wonderfully
beautiful.  and paradoxically dramatic because
well, death was there and we didn't have
any supplies because
military planes don't carry food like
commercial planes do, so
in total there was a can of
seafood that we shared between 27 of us,
two or three chocolates, there was a
cherry.  It was a liquid that
we drank a small glass so we each
divided and that day is the day that
two planes pass above us, they pass
twice that we thought they were
planes, well we knew they were
search planes but they had seen us, I
remember this one.  We shouted at them, we
celebrated, we celebrated, convinced that they
had seen us. I remember that there was
half a bottle of Whiskey that we
drank with Roberto Canesa. It's because they
hadn't seen us and that's where we started
waiting for them to come pick us up.
Gustavo Nicolich was the manager.  From
listening to the radio we had a small
Radio Marca Espica which was what was
fashionable and we listened to the news to see
where the search was coming from.
Suddenly on the 10th he
heard the news that they were no
longer looking for us and he asked me about it, he told me.
Carlitos, perhaps because I was the boy,
says I have good news to give. I happened to
listen to a Chilean radio where the
announcer said that they have finished
the search for the Uruguayan plane and they are going to come
look for our remains in
February. When the ice comes,
but  I tell him, but it's good news,
son, it's good news. He asks me if
we don't have anything and he said yes,
Carlitos, it's good news because now we
have to find our own
resources. I say, but we have
absolutely nothing and he told me we have to
find them and  there the story changes and
the attitude changes to stop waiting
to start acting there we
realized that the story was our
story that depended only on
us Because the whole world
had abandoned us or at least
we saw it that
way immediately they begin to
important characters emerge in the story,
there were three
first-year medical students, Canesa
Servino and Storm, who assume their role as
doctors, helping the injured and
even helping those who died. Roy,
who was also a
first-year engineering student,  engineering had a
manual skill to remove the
seats inside the fuselage and designed
an antenna to listen to the radio he
assumed himself as an engineer he began to believe
that he was an engineer this Adolfo Strach
had the ability to invent things
he invented the way to walk on the
snow with  the seat cushions
he invented a way to cover us against the
cold by removing the fabric that covered the
cushions he invented black glasses he
cut the mica from the
front of the plane to make glasses
because the snow burns you uh they burn
your eyes he invented  the way to make water
because melting water 25 grams below zero is
very difficult and well, with some silver cans he
put snow on top and through the
mirror effect we managed to melt water
drop after drop, that is, everyone
assumed their role, it was my turn, I had one
manual skill to
cover the plane so that the cold would not get in
and what's more, I even had a title as an
official bricker, which
began to turn me into a
useful character. I mean the fact that I had that
ability, I began to realize that it was
[Music  ]
hunger is important. The hunger we have now is different here. Going
to
lunch is a
different hunger. When several days go by and
the only thing you feel is a pain in your
stomach and you know that if you don't eat you will
die, that is, it is  one more reasoned thing
You've already lost that feeling of wanting to eat
a sandwich es es The
stomach pain of not eating absolutely
anything is horrible and that's when you realize that
that idea begins to arise in everyone at the same time and begins to emerge in
all without anyone talking to them.
The first comment I feel is
sorry to Nando, I'm a [ __ ] when I tell him there is
nothing left in the pantry, which was where
we kept that can of seafood, and
Carlitos tells me, I eat the pilot, which
is also a natural comment.  because
he had lost his mother in the
accident, his sister in the accident, it is
seen that on a conscious or
unconscious level he was holding on to the
pilot.
friends and then I
realize that I was also
thinking it but I didn't dare to say it.
The youngest of them all told it
to Adolfo Strauch in an act of cowardice on
my part. I tell him, I blame Nando. I tell him,
Adolfo Nando is here.  The crazy guy wants to
eat the pilot and Adolfo tells me no.
Carlitos is not that crazy. My
cousins ​​and I already thought about it when we received
the news on the 10th that they
were no longer looking for us. That's when
the only idea begins to emerge in everyone at the same time.  It is
possible that it is to feed on
our dead companions because there
is no other
chance. The first thing we did was a
solemn pact between all of us that
if any of us died he would be at the
disposal of the others and the second
thing we did was entrust the
students with  of medicine who had
assumed their role as doctors to
take care of the matter and they took care of the poor
medical students. A
first-year medical student
had never seen a dead person either. I mean,
but since they had assumed their role and
believed themselves to be doctors, they really assumed that
role.  and we resolved an issue that we had
to resolve because we had the
most sacred of rights, which was the
right to life and the right to return
home, the scale of values ​​changes
abruptly in those circumstances and
one begins to give the real value to
what family has what life and
the law is I was fighting for my
life so you live it in a
different way where you don't have the opportunity
to cry I say you are fighting You
can be the next So you are
fighting for your own your own
life  You couldn't allow yourself that
pain, I think it's a
defense mechanism that human beings have
for me. Honestly, it was the worst
day in all of history because it
was when you feel that God turns you around and
stabs you in the back
because we had experienced the accident, we
had received the  I noticed that they were not
looking for us. We had made the decision to
feed our
dead companions and on top of that it was 3 in the afternoon
when suddenly we heard the noise like
a herd of horses coming down and
suddenly tons of snow
got inside the fuselage.  and they don't bury
us, we come from a country where there is no
snow, that is, we don't know that these
things can happen and we were all
buried except Roy Harley and I, who
were left with our faces uncovered and we looked at each other
saying, we are left alone in
history and Roy can come out.  And I went out and we
began to discover whoever
we could from under the snow and when I
arrived at my two friends who were
in front of me, they were both dead.
We were buried for three days.
That was October 29.
October 30 was our birthday.  by Numa
turcatti that with the sense of humor
that I have I told you Gentlemen today is
Numa's birthday they tell me Carlitos And
what do you intend to celebrate I say to the
extent that we are alive it is
worth it and and it happened on October 31st which was
my  birthday I turned 19 at 4200
Met altitude buried by an
avalanche and I told them Today is my
birthday and they call me Carlitos And what do
you intend to celebrate I say to the extent
that we are alive it is worth it and
the first of November arrived which was the
my father's birthday in Montevideo and
that motivated me, along with Roy Harley, to
remove the window from the pilot's cabin
and we went out to the roof of the plane that
was level with snow. I remember that it was
a splendid day but what
motivated me was to go out  to greet my
father to convey his Happy Birthday
but above all things to
convey to him that I was free from that
hell of snow and the avalanche
changes history again and to find
the positive within the negative the
only thing that was positive  the avalanche
was that it broke with The small groups
we were five
inseparable friends three others remained There were
four inseparable friends two
others remained there were three inseparable friends and
one remained and from the avalanche onwards
we became a single group and
our story becomes one  of
the most notable stories of
teamwork and we gradually transformed
into a kind of machine to
live with what one contributed with what
another contributed and we all began to
work so that Nando parrado Roberto
canesa and vicentín would go out for a walk
giving them  We did the best we could to them and
worked so that they could move
forward,
but after two days they returned with the
news that they had found the much-
sought tail of the plane, which
had all of our luggage in the tail of the plane.
But it also had the batteries.  from the
plane that gave us the chance to be able to
join them to the radio transmitter to
talk on the radio or we believed and they returned
to look for Roy Harley who was the
engineer who was supposed to know something about
Electricity And poor Roy was the
only thing he had done in his life  It was
to change the Pasac of his
cousins' car for another Pasac cassette player and
we inflicted on him the most
brutal task, which was to join 160 cables that
were upstairs with 160 cables that were
downstairs to operate a device
that he had never seen in his life. There  They
take Roy with the radio to the queue
and after three days they return
frustrated with the news that when
they put the cables together with the other cables
the only thing that happened was a short circuit and
the
illusion was broken. They arrived from the queue frustrated
but with some joy.  They brought some
clothes, all of our luggage was there,
they brought 131 boxes of cigarettes and
they also brought from the queue a piece of
quilted fabric that was used to
insulate the air conditioning and
heating of the plane
and when I see it I say this can be
transformed into  a sleeping bag and I
start sewing a sleeping bag that
I made so, so well made that not even
Cristian dior makes a sleeping bag
like the one I made. What I'm going for was my
pride was what I about that boy who  It was of no use to me. I
had to
be the upholsterer on the plane, removing the
snow from inside the fuselage after
the avalanche. I had to make the
sleeping bag, which is the greatest pride
of the things I have done in my life, and
there  Day 60 arrives for me, the most
important day in history, which is when
Parrado Canea Bentín and
my sleeping bag go out for a walk and here
the only Heroic event in history happens for me and
it happens at that moment I go out for a walk
He turns back and tells me
Carlitos before leaving I want to give you a I
want to give you a kiss to the cross of your
Rosary that I had a rosary that
my mother had given me that was very
important and in exchange he gave me a
shoe I had bought him a pair  of
sneakers in Mendoza when
his nephew's plane stopped and Carlitos told me, I'll
take the other one and I
promise you that I'll come pick up the pair,
but if that doesn't happen and I don't go back to
look for the pair, I mean, I'll die.  on the
road and you have to use the
body of my mother and my sister to
feed yourself, do
it. Not only did he have the
guts, let me put it this way, to go out and
look for help at the cost of
dying, but he also gave us
unnecessary authorization but  He
fed us with the most sacred thing he
had, which was his mother, sister, that
makes Nando a great man who
always deserves only a great man, he does
one of those things and they go out for a walk and it was
exasperating, what they thought of going up
in one day, it took them so long.  Three days for three
days we saw the little dots moving away and on the
third day we saw that one of those
little dots was going down and we thought
well, the other two have died from
so much negative news and we went to
meet them. It took 3 hours to go down, what
had taken three days to go down.
climb up and when we reached it it was
vicentín who came with the news that they
had reached the top of the
mountains and when they looked towards the other
side instead of finding the green
Chilean meadows which was what we
assumed there should be they
found  a pathetic and
desolate panorama that was mountains and more
mountains and more mountains and there they made the
crazy and gray decision to take away the
food that Vicentín had and his clothes and
they sent him to the fuselage with a message for
all of us that the two of them were going to
continue  Go ahead even until
you die. The 70th day of The
story arrives. I remember that I was
hugging José Luis. I began to cry
desperately. It was a story that was not
resolved. 70 days, 10 days had passed and we
had lost contact with
Perrado and Canesa. Surely they would
have  dead, there were three days left until
Christmas, which was a day, a
very important date for us, I was crying
uncontrollably and don't ask me
why, because all of a sudden my
head changes and I become positive, I have
a kind of premonition that I'm going to be
gray and gray.  They had arrived
somewhere but I didn't dare to comment on it, the
good news is not commented on.
Daniel Fernández woke up and told me
Carlitos, I just dreamed that I was standing on
one side, I told him, I have the same
feeling and we turned on the radio and the
first news  What we heard was
saying a Uruguayan plane and suddenly
we heard the Voice of the Uruguayan ambassador
César Charlone who was at the
Pudahuel airport who says gentlemen,
I must say that it is official that
Fernando Parrado and Roberto
Canesa have appeared. Imagine what it was like
for us Listening to those two  names
because only by hearing those names
did we know that it was the end of our
story The end of our fight the
end of our pain but above all
things It was the beginning of
freedom it was what we had
fought for they don't know what we hugged they don't
know  What we cried, we seemed crazy
around the radio set that was
lying in the snow, it was a moment of
madness and not only does the ambassador say that,
but he says and at this
moment I dismiss the helicopters that
are going to look for Parrado and Canesa so that they can
be  They are the ones who lead them to the
mountain and we hear on the radio the
helicopters taking off, a
wonderful and good noise. Knowing that they
were coming to look for us, we fulfill the
Traveler's ritual. When we go on a
trip, we all fulfill a ritual and I
fulfilled mine.  The first thing
I did was shave,
my father always said that shaving is
getting rid of the worries of the
previous day and I, applying Dad's philosophy,
said yes, I shave. I take away the
history of the Andes, but of course
shaving here with hot water is not the same as shaving here with hot water.
In the Andes at 25 below zero I
destroyed my face but well I shaved the
second thing I did was comb my hair with
hair gel which was the only thing that saved us from
eating in the Cordillera because the
Gina is really filthy but I combed my hair
and the third thing I  I did was pack my
suitcase, well-combed, very poorly
shaved, with my suitcase packed, we
sat down to wait for the arrival of the
helicopters, which took longer
than we thought. And suddenly,
looking at that Valley where we had never
seen anything, absolutely nothing, we began
to feel in  the distance that
wonderful noise that when you see a
helicopter you will remember me
because it is felt from very far away that they
began to get closer and
closer until suddenly they burst into
that Valley I saw them as two
gigantic birds carrying  of freedom, I
imagine what it may have been like for
the pilots' heads to see
us. In fact, that photo of us
all with our arms raised is one of
the most important photos of the
last century and they begin to turn and
begin to go down.  and when they were 3
Met high, three
characters from the Chilean Andean group got down
and when one of them fell on
the snow he began to shout my name, his name was
Sergio Díaz and he began Who
is Carlitos Páez Who is Carlitos Páez
Who is Carlitos Páez  and I say and this
to me Where do you know me from, I fell
70 days ago I don't even know where and I tell you it's me, it's
not that I have two letters for you
like two letters for me and he hands me two
papers written in red the first of
They said this, dear Carlitos Miguel,
as I have never failed you, I wait for you with more faith
in God than ever, your mother has now arrived
in Chile again, a hug from the old man and then I
realize that behind my story there
was another story. What a beautiful thing
I could have been.  What happened to me was that I realized,
above all, that it made sense
that on that first day of November,
Dad's birthday, I would have gone out to greet
his birthday. And what a beautiful thing
I could have been experiencing at that moment, and
when I opened the second letter that had
a  drawn helicopter said Hello
guys here I'm sending you a helicopter as a
Christmas present. For me it is one of the
most beautiful things that has happened to me. I
think it is a story of young people. I
think it clearly marks our
history that it can be clearly marked
that we must  living that is a bit like
Saint Francis of Assisi who says
start by doing what is necessary then
what is possible and you end up doing the
impossible and it is a story of struggle for
life which is actually the most
precious thing that human beings have is
life in this really
brutal story of the common human being because
that is what our story has, it
is an extraordinary story
starring ordinary people, any
of those who are here filming or
interviewing could have been part of
the story, it is not a merit of mine.  It is a
merit of the human being who has the
ability to evolve and transform
to get ahead. There are more of us than those who
left on that plane. We are really
more. There are more than 12 descendants in
my personal case. Thanks to the fact that I am
alive, there are eight more. I have two children.  and
I have six grandchildren. So
this whole story was worth it so that what
triumphs is life. I call on people
to look back
at their own mountain ranges because
each of you has your own
mountain range, it is not mine, the most important thing
is  each one's because it is each
one's but what it is about is looking
back but going forward
looking for the positive within the
negative [Music]
islands we Had no water and no Food as
we thought then